[Applause]
these women are some of the most badass
athletes you've ever seen my name is
Kelly Cantwell I'm also known as Monster
Mash in my previous life I was an HR
professional and now I'm a roller
skating instructor for the Kansas City
Roller warriors and an aspiring roller
derby girl being a mom is a very
interesting job my husband is Chris and
then we have two boys Emerson and Eliot
that's the four of us we are very busy
I had this super stressful crazy hectic
more than full time job working as a
director of HR for a non-profit I always
thought that roller derby would be an
awesome way to like let out some
aggression
[Applause]
we started having kids and I heard about
this program that was like Fitness
skating it was drills and scaled based
on roller derby but no impact with other
skaters so there was no risk of injury
and I absolutely fell in love with it
then Chris accepted the job to teach
here and I started up the local Kansas
City branch of that group I still
remember when we bought the Subaru we
were expecting Emerson we wanted to get
something a little bigger that felt a
little safer when I think of Subaru I do
think of an active lifestyle people are
using their Subarus
to go skiing or go hiking or go play ice
hockey or roller derby we've always got
bags of gear in the back we've got ice
hockey gear for Emerson my roller derby
bag that's just how we roll
when I brought Derby light here with me
I knew no one I had to reach out to
ranks I had to find people who would
want to do this like new skating program
when I was in HR it was something that I
definitely took home with me at night it
was really hard on my family now I get
to do something I absolutely love like
I'm passionate about it and I'm hanging
out with friends when skaters have
completed their learn to skate classes
they can go to their warriors and
training program which has been how they
get drafted to be on a competitive
league team I'm actually signed up to
start the warriors and training program
next month so hopefully in a couple
months you'll be able to see Monster
Mash as part of one of the local home
teams I just made it really official
seeing that - right now with all these
guys the challenges just seems more
connected when things feel super busy
even with things that we love I want to
make sure that we are still moving
forward with all of us with our goals
we'll just keep going after what we love
and make sure that we're cheering each
other up yeah
sky's the limit
you